les duos trios blacks le concept est
très simple on a le choix de films ou
trois films duo deux films au choix
parmi une belle sélection tels que
sybille pouvaient parler ils se jettent
pouvait parler plus de yao également de
réty give et puis greenbook sur les
routes du sud
le principe c'est justement c'est de
pouvoir découvrir des films qui ont un
caractère intéressant de par leur sujet
on parle de la ségrégation pas des
erreurs judiciaires commises as you des
des noirs américains
on parle également de la recherche de
ces deux de sa famille de d&d de ses
origines il ya des sujets très fort et
puis on a également des acteurs noirs
comme omar sy comme michael jordan qu'on
a pu voir dans dans black panther on
aura également beaucoup d'autres acteurs
qui sont pas forcément connus mais qui
sont kiki qui ont une interprétation
émouvante le plus souvent est magnifique
de l'initiative sécurisé où il y avait
de la demande
et bien c'est il y avait de la demande
effectivement c'est pas la première fois
qu'on fait ce genre d'opération on l'a
fait il ya quelques années avec des
films portés par morgan freeman entre
autres et dès que l'occasion se présente
c'est pour nous l'opportunité de
permettre à tout un chacun de découvrir
des films qui serait peut-être pas à les
voir autrement